honestly I don't think I've ever looked
better hello everyone its Alicia ballon
somewhere under here
welcome to Fandango indie movie Guide
I'm wearing this because I'm talking
about two films with ghosts in the title
but hangups it's too hard left anyway
this is in relation to my first movie a
ghost story a movie that was very
divisive at the Sundance Film Festival
and I dare say many people are gonna not
get into this movie but many people like
me will love it this is directed by
David Lowery who did ain't them bodies
saints and he brings together Rooney
Mara and Casey Affleck once again they
play a married couple and quite quickly
she has to deal with a tragic loss when
he dies in a car accident he comes back
in the form of a ghost but not just any
ghost a ghost that looks like me at the
side of this video a Halloween II type
loaf a kind of ghost and that's where
your first leap of faith really comes in
for me I quite quickly forgot the
gimmick and I really got into the mood
of the film it was very haunting you
might say but for others I know that
they couldn't quite get past scene Casey
Affleck underneath the sheet the
cinematography though is beautiful long
takes slow scenes I don't mind a film
that really takes its time and telling
the story and at the center of this all
is a story of tragedy of love of loss
and dealing with grief what is it you
like about this house so much history
there is one scene that will be very
talked about it's where Rooney Mara eats
an entire chocolate pie in one sitting
the kind of scene that again some people
may find a little bit too hard to get
into like a joke that continues to keep
going but for me I I started off so
giggling and then I really let myself be
swept away the whole thing is a little
bit Terrence mal
like a little bit Chantal Akerman I
really like the way David Lowery seems
to be pushing himself artistically with
this movie whether it's to RT for you or
just RT enough you have to admire
someone that really goes for the
boundaries and try something unique and
different particularly in this age of
kind of films you can see a ghost story
in limited theaters from Friday it
builds our legacy piece by piece and
maybe the whole world will remember you
and maybe just a couple of people but
you do what you can to make sure you're
still around after they're gone
[Music]
my other ghosts movie is a very
different kind of film
it's called city of ghosts since a
brilliant documentary P that is highly
unworthy or dude I also a soulish - may
I have another ball -
whispered mo no more tea Ord this is
directed by Matthew Hyneman who did
cartel land back in 2015 an
oscar-nominated documentary here he
looks at Syria which has been under
civil war for so long and particularly
this group of citizen journalists who go
deep into Syria to try to uncover
secrets and mysteries and facts about
Isis much of the footage comes from
these journalists themselves and they're
really risking their lives putting their
life on the line to deliver these
stories they work in secret and under
constant threat reporting on the
depredations of isis in their home city
some have fled in fear for their own
lives even in exile they are in no way
safe you get to meet each of these
reporters in each of their families and
really find out why they do what they do
it gives you great hope in the power of
journalism as well as being
heartbreaking and terrifying at the same
time I think it's important to watch a
documentary like this and really get an
understanding of exactly what is going
on Sunday's masala vada Medina Robert
another clear
in window you can see city of ghosts in
limited theaters from this Friday I know
no add more I've never worn a bum
shamrock of him oh they have a really
quick one today but I just wanted to
tell you about these two ghost stories
because they had two very different
films with ghosts in the title but
absolutely well worth your money trust
me save your pennies go and see them if
you can if they're playing near you
right away first you have a ghost story
starring Rooney Mara and Casey Affleck
and then city of ghosts the documentary
directed by Matthew Hyneman I released
him alone you can find me at Alesia
Malone on Twitter or I always read your
comments so if you leave one below if
you're watching on YouTube I will
respond I love to hear what you're
watching and what you're interested in
and when you've seen these films whether
you like them or not I'll see you next
time bye